Oh
[Musique]
déjà ces micro dumps génèrent quand
est-ce que tous certains incidents brûlants lo
ce qui produit évidemment vrai
Pollution de l'air
et en effet aussi certains
sont situés à proximité de lieux publics
[Musique]
nous en profitons
une matière première pour fabriquer notre
panneaux d'isolation thermique
parce que la principale chose à éliminer le
déchets textiles du Chili et éduquer les
les personnes qui peuvent réduire leur consommation
de textiles inutiles et qu'ils
prendre en charge l'allongement de la durée de vie
ce
mais lors de l'achat et de la poursuite
voir cochon avant dans zara h&m était
pour voir vos anciens et les magasins qui sont
plus orienté vers l'échec
[Musique]